[موسيقى] في
أوائل الربيع وعاد الديك الرومي الغربي
على قيد الحياة بعد نومه الشتوي
في غضون بضعة أشهر ، حيث ستمتلئ هذه الأشجار
بالفاكهة
وستكون المنطقة مزدحمة
بالسياح ،
ومن الجميل أن أكون هنا في هذا الوقت
من العام
عندما يكون هناك  جو حقيقي من
الاحتمالات والفرص
[موسيقى
] تقع قرية شيريندي الخلابة على بعد
حوالي ساعة جنوب إزمير ،
إنها رحلة رائعة لا ينبغي لأحد أن
يفوتها
اليوم ، أنا ضيف على موزدا توم بيكيتي
الذي يدير فندقًا هنا عندما لا
تنمو  المحاصيل وصنع زيت الزيتون الخاص بها
يتأرجح كثيرًا في اليوم بالطاقة والحياة ، لقد
أتت إلى هنا لأول مرة من اسطنبول
في أوائل الثمانينيات من القرن الماضي
، لقد رأت شيئًا مميزًا
ولم تغادر أبدًا
mudja لديها العديد من المواهب ومن بينها
أعطتني جولة حول سبب مجيئي إلى
هنا  في المقام الأول إيفسوس ، هذه
مدينة قديمة على مرمى حجر
من قريتها حيث يزورها السياح من
جميع أنحاء العالم
لتتعجب من العجائب الأثرية.
مرشد سياحي هو
المؤرخ القديم الذي سيقدم لي الحقائق
التي ستعطيني المشاعر
[موسيقى
] ومثل التمثيل المزدوج الذي تم التدرب عليه جيدًا ،
يذهبون ذهابًا وإيابًا لتعزيز
قصص بعضهم البعض وإثراء زيارتي
كانت fss مدينة رئيسية في  الإمبراطورية الرومانية
واحدة من أغنى المدن في
رخام شرق البحر الأبيض المتوسط ​​، يمكنك رؤية الرخام
والفسيفساء والتماثيل الرائعة في كل مكان ،
نحن الآن في وسط المدينة ،
الواجهة التي تراها هناك هي
واجهة مكتبة قديمة تسمى
مكتبة سيلسيوس التي بناها
أحد أهم المواطنين في هذه
المدينة التي تعيش في هذه المدينة ، هل يمكنك أن تتخيل
دخولك في مكان رخامي في هذه المكتبة
المليئة بالأعمدة والسيدات اللطيفات
وأنت في عالم آخر كان
يسمى هذا شارع كوريت  كان
التصحيح هو النبلاء في ephesus ، لذا كانت الشوارع
متماشية مع تماثيلهم ، مما
يمنحك شعورًا
بالرفاهية والرفاهية وثراء
المدينة التي تم بناؤها بشكل رائع إذا كان بإمكاني
النقر فوقك  كتف وأرسل لك
إلى هناك ما هو الشيء الوحيد الذي
تود رؤيته أريد أن أسير في شوارع
إفيسوس لأننا قيل لنا أن
الأشخاص الذين يرتدون ملابس فاخرة للغاية هنا
وأرغب في رؤية هذه المسابقة مستمرة.
طباخ وهذه الفوضى مهمان للغاية وفي
العصور القديمة كان هناك
مطعم للوجبات السريعة
يسمى Thermopylae أود أن أذهب إلى هناك ودفع
فلسًا واحدًا وأكل ما
يطبخونه في يوم واحد هنا لقد التهمت
مناظر رائعة تقول  إذا أسقطت
العملة المعدنية ، يمكنك سماع ذلك ، فأنا لا أعتقد ذلك ،
هل سمعت ذلك
نعم وأثريت ذهني وروحي
بالحضارات القديمة ، فلا تقلق
سأكون هنا طوال الأسبوع ولم أنتهي
بعد من
[موسيقى]
أنت